there's mud there's rocks there's roots
there's street fields there's high
alpine meadows low valleys I can't be
full canopy running through with sword
ferns cutting your shins and quads wide
open trails where you can see exactly
where you want to go five miles down the
mountain I do love it all - most of us
completing a marathon would be a
lifetime accomplishment - a growing
number of long-distance runners though
that's just a warm-up defined as any
race greater in distance than the
standard 26.2 mile marathon ultra
marathons are typically 5,400 miles long
ultra trail run would be that same thing
on their trails mountainous preferably
over the last decade elite runner Chris
email has run and won ultra trail races
around the world a couple of races that
I've had the opportunity to compete in
are the hardrock 100 which boasts a
34,000 feet of game which is pretty
similar to starting at sea level
summiting Everest and returning to sea
level all on a day these races typically
last 24 hours so that means running at
night to bleep 100 miler the runners
methodically calculate their pace
hydration and caloric intake as
exhaustion sets in the support crew
helps a runner stay nourished and on
pace
the well-trained athlete can burn
anywhere from 600 to a thousand calories
per hour depending on your output and
100 mile race you're not working at that
high high level the whole time but it's
a constant movement so I would say
you're on the low end may be burning 500
calories an hour
multiply that by say 25 hours this kind
of exertion can exact a heavy toll on a
runner's body issues that you can have
out while running longer distance races
whether it's 50 miles 100 miles or
further could be as basic as blisters on
your feet dehydration organs can suffer
from not having the right levels of
sodium magnesium potassium trace
minerals and fluids in your body
Chrissie once ran a race where she lost
her vision when her eyes began to freeze
and severe winter cold her toughness is
matched only by her passion for the
sport
I think the key components of being an
ultra trail runner first and foremost is
the passion for it and the love of just
being out there on the trails in the
mountains
that's why I do it
you